a new haven police officer charged in a
deadly crash while here in las vegas
remains in jail right now i'm heather
mills robert ferraro facing a judge this
morning for the crash that killed fellow
officer joshua castellano bianca holman
live outside the regional justice center
to tell us exactly what happened in
court today bianca
[Music]
34 year old robert ferrara was driving a
rolls royce friday morning when he lost
control and crashed it along spring
mountain and decatur 35 year old joshua
castellano was ejected and died ferrero
faces dui resulting in death and
reckless driving today's hearing
discussed potential attorney
representation
high profile attorney gabriel grosso
could be representing ferraro he told
the court he was contacted by the family
grosso tells us he has not been formally
hired yet right now it's too early to
tell if ferraro will be able to leave
the state that will be determined by the
judge as of right now ferrara will
remain in jail
now attorney grossel told the court that
family members just arrived in nevada
matter of fact we saw him meeting with
those three individuals after this
morning's hearing and also we know that
ferrero will be back in court on
thursday at 7 30 a.m reporting from
downtown las vegas bianca holman 8 news
now